looks like we're back I'm going to have
to update all the router
modem firmware later tonight because
this just keeps cutting out and we'll
see if that fixes it hopefully it does
otherwise I'm going to have to be on
support with the
moronic
VY we'll see looks like we're back for
now
that re to
cat
output wait RE 2
right but how does this make it break
how does this make it
break let's
see
oh hold on I think I fixed
it
anything they should be doing stuff
right
this
lagging yeah you can see it's dropping
some frames we're going to have to
improve the uh the com implementation I
suppose but still not bad that I have a
network like this
running um completely unoptimized
C and it's still 45
FPS we'll fix the perf but this is not
bad at
all it's funny that the neutrals just
like wreck
you what did I forget to
deallocate oh the texture yeah that's
actions and we've also got to load uh
weights into this don't we and the next
two things to do
I'm trying to think how I want to go
about doing
honest it's just tricky because
like
yeah we'll mess with it a little bit for
now
it's pretty awkward actually now that
I'm looking at
it well let's just
do yeah it's like it's awkward because
you're going to need to
compute the size is and offset for
everything
we're going to have to change stuff
quite a
bit because I didn't account for this
properly before
wrong
tab this is cool to
weights and then what we'll do is we'll
do struct
weights it's going to be it's going to
contain float star
idx and then what we're going to
do is we're going to do weight star load
weights I kind of
like how do I want to do this
I'm getting caught up in like a lot of
little details that don't
matter let's just do it the way that
I've been doing it so we'll do like this
data load weights
right and this has to go down
here so now we have this loaded into a
struct that also has this index here and
then now how do I actually use it is the
question
do let's just do float star get
weights into num
weights
data index and weights return data
this is
size wait size num
wavs and then we can just
assert then this is weights index less
than equal weight size
perfect and then what we can do is we
can modify
the the init functions of our
layers to take this weights buffer thing
weights we'll see whether that ends up
being a good idea or not
but I think that's what we're going to
do for now
make
linear so this has got to
be weight star weights
right layer weights is going to be get
weights
this layer bias going to get
weights output
DM that's
nice it's nice and easy
xtram are we uh are we
down
no oh that's actually on the X servers
for once that's
interesting uh it's doing something
weird it's definitely doing something
weird
don't need it for
reos do it for here wait our
weights let me just make sure it's not
making a million posts on my channel
no it's not
okay it still says live but I don't know
what it's doing because I have unable to
connect in my restream
iio so if you're watching on X and it's
freezing or whatever try YouTube neurl
MMO where twitch jar is
layer eight star
weights wait state
state and actually almost all of these
[Music]
need
wait State H is get State H gets
this St C gets
this bias
put by
state okay so we get the weights for the
lstm and I think that's everything that
actually has
weights and now I have to actually
figure out the exact size of the
network um so we'll figure that
out I think it's like 150k
cool now this thing has
weights well let's see if we uh we can
build this getting ahead of myself
weights H that's weird
right it's right
here Ty death struct weights
that conflicting types for load
weights oh right I
okay that's
better float
data weights
data this is
and and then you have to Hash include
assert do
be like
this okay
directory
um so all the agents are like very
slowly
and I can't control the agent anymore
which is even
weirder oh also I'm realizing that this
doesn't need to run every
frame this only needs to run there
right so that should actually way speed
us up I was trying to do the Nets every
single
frame so now we're back to 60 FPS
running the neurom met at least without
any
optimization
but ORD
wrong this is
Neo grand total of two
plugins NE
uh SEI because python syntax
highlighting is a total pain and uh the
main reason I have it is for super
Maven the code complete
I don't advise using you know GPT YK or
um Sonet to like give you giant chunks
of code but like on line autocomplete is
basically just a typing buff right look
how fast it
is no LSP no
formatter uh no formatter no LSP I don't
have I don't have any opposition I just
don't have
one mainly because I like I was
previously coding in Python so much that
like you can't do all that much with
those anyways since it's not statically
typed I probably could get one for C it
would help a little bit but not a huge
deal I see why I can't control the
character here it's just cuz I have this
in a weird order
right if I did hold
on Step
n and then you do
forward and do it like
this
ah okay look I can control the
character and now I'm controlling this
one and this one is being taken over by
the neural Net's clearly not being
loaded correctly or something right
we'll have to debug it but like I have
control now I have control over this one
now I have control over this one and
like you can see the other ones moving a
little bit so the general setup of this
is good and it's 60fps running in a
single core with like this giant well
not giant it's really small but you know
this multi-layer convet lstm everything
works we have like typical mobile
controls we've got click to to move
we've got hold to move which you know is
fine but you know you have click to move
we should probably make it so that like
you get like responsiveness like for
where you click or
whatever but you have this you've got
your abilities so like you
know uh well there's something wrong
with the ability hot keys I think but
yeah can you explain why it's not
possible to use the C file you get
that's a good
question I have not tried that to be
fair it's kind of a mess though I
that's
so include python. is there like python
stuff in here or can you use
this I mean this is a freaking 55,000
line file
gross if you want to go ahead and try
that like let me
I mean to be fair I didn't try that hard
but the thing is like at this point it's
become it's let's see it would be it
would work that would be super cool to
get the m to play on yeah and I mean
absolutely that would be great for
contributors
um I've been writing these CMS for like
a couple of weeks and already it's not
really any harder for me to write in C
versus scon the one thing that you have
to realize though with scon though is
like it includes the python interpreter
by default and it will call back into
python so even though that this is C it
like this has calls back into python so
you have to make sure your program has
zero of those and then you probably will
have to do something to like cut out the
python interpreter entirely so it won't
be
trivial if you have a way of doing that
let me know but I mean for now you know
I I contributors are perfectly welcome
to contribute uh you know in scyon or
whatever they want to write it in as
long as it's fast and uh you know if you
want help getting it onto the web I can
help with that but really the C is not
hard like I've been doing this for a
couple of weeks and it's already just as
easy to do it in C in fact I actually
think it's easier in C and I know that
sounds crazy but the thing is like the
build times are so much faster and the
error message are the error messages are
much better so like the dev cycle is
just so much easier and
Tighter
it I've been enjoying it at the very
least train the agent in Python and then
use C to run with wome yep exactly now
the tricky thing here which is why this
file exists is you have to be able to
load the net Indy which is why I have
this C puffer net uh I'm currently
debugging this but like right now I have
it running it's just either loading the
wrong weights are doing something weird
I just you know this has only been in
development for a few days now um these
guys are technically being controlled by
a neural net so we have 10 agents
controlled by neural net 60 FPS is you
know zero lag One Core running a two
layer CNN plus MLP plus lstm uh
Inc is it not POS possible use Python
with a W nope you can't really do that
as far as I'm
aware got to compile the web
assembly pytorch doesn't have great web
support either like I tried to like get
pytorch for web that didn't work they
have a C++ API but you can't just easily
compile it for web so like I mean at end
of the day though this is a 445 line
file that has lstm comms mop has a bunch
of stuff in
it right
now I got to figure out what's wrong
with
these um easiest way is going to be to
go layer by
layer and print out the weights
right you don't use torch did you
implement everything in the network
yourself or yeah I just implemented it
all
myself when I load the weights but like
look I have this puffet file it's again
it's 445 lines and most of that is just
for user API to make it a little easier
to store weights and stuff like this is
the com
2D this is your lstm right here they're
like you know half screen a code a piece
so like when you actually get down to
the low level of what these things are
they don't take a lot of code to
implement that's
it pretty cool
right four Loops from
hell I mean yes to know right like I
actually I posted this on Twitter and
people like a seven4 Loops but like this
is how you write a con
right messages are
censored that's weird they shouldn't be
I turned off the profanity filter though
I don't know if uh it might reset it
every stream by default which is
obnoxious but yeah like this is how you
implement a comp right like there's no
reason to try to split this up into
multiple functions that's just dumb
because then like you you add additional
stuff to the stack technically you can
inline it but like there's really no
reason not to just have this be seven4
Loops like when you're processing data
you know when you're processing data in
a way that truly requires seven4 Loops
you just write seven4 Loops right
let's print out some weights here let's
print out the
weights did I forget something
[Music]
compile what is it
what are you doing
Nathan oh that's
funny I I don't know YouTube is really
weird
zero
oops no dots allowed yeah I think it
doesn't it tries to censor all types of
URLs I've tried to find a setting to
disable that and I
can't which is really weird because like
I've gotten zero bots on YouTube and I
get like tons of twitch Bots tons of
twitch
Bots I got one that was like either a
script or a language model as well the
other day where it was like timing its
messages to try to like you know guess
what I was going to reply and then try
to sell me stuff it was like trying to
fake having a conversation it was so
stupid
right so what the the plan here is going
to be to uh to print this stuff out and
then we have this save net flat file
here where's
this test
lstm question sent but you didn't read
it oh should I look in at m.p and m.h
for writing the MC how do you bind and
comile okay so if you want to write it
and see then yeah you should look at
these files um and then I have like a
build. P it's literally clang it's so
easy uh now when you want to run to
python there is a PIX file that is a
very thin binding that literally just
goes between Python and c and the reason
I do that is then you have like The
Binding as its own thing and you don't
have to clutter your python or clutter
your C code and you can use the C
Standalone you can use the python
Standalone and it's just in the middle
so that's what I would suggest and I'll
be here you can ask me stuff like I said
I will help you a ton with that
environment because it's awesome hey
welcome what is this this is me
currently trying to get a network
working
for this MOBA I
have so I'm trying to get neuronet to
play this and I have trained agents that
will play it but the thing is I have to
Port them into C so that I can run them
on the web so I'm currently writing
neural net layers in C for this it's a
fair complicated one it's like a MLP CNN
lstm that I'm getting to work here and
we actually have it almost done I just
have to debug
it and I have to basically figure out
where it is that my implementation isn't
matching the P torch
reference so that's
it
ram ram
tape
data cpu.
numpy
Z does this
okay no knowledge when it comes to this
that's an interesting
project my main thing is I do ultra high
performance reinforcement learning and
um these days the push is on high
performance simulators uh which we have
some of but in order to show them off
I've been putting them on the web lately
I've just been porting a bunch of stuff
bunch of these M to C and then also now
porting the networks to C so that we can
run them end to end on web like 100%
client side and they're actually fast
enough that we can run the M we can run
like thousand times real time easily but
now we can even run the networks real
time uh on one CPU core which is pretty
cool like Comet
lstm one CPU core
so it's 100% client
side is cool very
anything how do I figure out what layer
this is
from I
torch
get layer
of
works a very very
nice very nice
indeed so this is what we wanted out of
this is now I I can run
this and yeah you see I get the first
weight of every
layer so then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to build this
here why do I not
have I thought that I uh on
oh cuz they didn't do
wait why do I not get these
prints I should have gotten print
statements here
ends oh the return is in the the return
is up
here yeah I'm just saw
that okay perfect so
now now we can see that we have the
wrong Network parameters right
we can see very clearly like hey look
the parameters don't
evening this is exciting though as soon
as I debug this we're going to be able
to upgrade the AI uh on the Moa we're
going to be able to
like actually run this thing online with
proper
AI so either goes
m.p plusi plus.
H during
training or Mah h plus neural
network Inc for web rendering yeah comma
correct question mark
God that's so
ridiculous here let me open the Discord
as well just in case that's
easier but yeah that's
um that's how it works and I want to be
fair Nathan I have
not I haven't been using the C ports for
training just
yet so that might be a little bit of a
different
ordeal I got to do
that but yeah it's whatever is easier
for you you can
do so when you write it in C technically
yeah you end up with this extra layer
because like you need the scon anyways
but the scon just becomes a very thin
wrapper with no logic in it
that's how it
goes okay so why don't these two
match uh I'm a little bit concerned with
that I thought at least we'd get like
the first layer to match Maybe
because like we call
make com 2D on weights
right now something's got to be wrong
there
okay so it says first weight is equal to
zero which is not
correct
there is this how I load though do I
just load from a PT oh no I don't load
from PT right why do I have a PT here
that doesn't make any sense
maybe could also just be I have a
different model
okay so Copy mobile
weights
bin or live environments ocean
MOA in and then
wa St in ah is this the same size or is
this changed I think it's changed
right one
six yeah it changed
look8 5 six that actually did
correct up here but it's not correct in
the
comp yeah so something's just getting
screwed up
we have weights
here make Comm
index let me make sure it has not
Advanced the
index ah wait wait idx is wrong isn't
it yeah I think I have the init function
wait wait what weights idx to
zero right when you load
it which data
we size we
uh oh okay
I
see we're good on the weight
index and then con
one
that see what
float star
data weights data of Weights
Index right
has got this many weights from index
zero and then it got 15K
interesting oh well right here is the
issue
yeah okay conv weight should match
now hello what are we doing we're
finally getting this network to work in
pure
CA pretty darn fancy Network to have to
port to Pure native
sea um but it's going to be really cool
because we're going to have a AET MLP
lstm running in the browser on One Core
in real time so that's going to be
pretty cool and all we have to do to get
there we're quite close
actually eight holy does this just work
immediately projection
bias projection weight
actor weight okay we get the actor
weight is wrong
here so we have to fix this I think it
does the recurrent before the actor or
something yeah yeah totally this is it
right here no is it
h almost we got all the way down to the
projection before it screws
up projection bias actually actually we
get all the way to the actor don't
we so it says
07 wait actor
weight projection
bias then actor the actor weight is
wrong why is the actor weight wrong
let's figure this
out projection is Right actor is right
okay so we
have actor
weight matches bias
matches value function
matches and
then and then we don't have the waight
for the lstm great so we have to get
that
then we do print
F lstm
weight and the lstm is
Jank okay let's see why it's
Jank let me just briefly vanity check
this
first oh we don't pass it anything
duh weight
star
weights and then it gets underscore
linear oh wait no I'm I'm dumb this is
this doesn't need to get
this make
lspm
weights c yeah so this is wrong here
this needs to be
Cal I don't know why it likes to do to
do this is
numbers this 14 here is
correct and then
these are
correct can this be faster than P
optimization
technically for like a specific very
specific Network coding it in see would
be faster than like naively optimized
python maybe eager mode python it could
be faster um it depends on like what
code it generates in compiled mode
anything we'll have to look at the data
but we are loading everything in
correctly
now is pretty
cool at least we should be pretty
confident we're loading stuff
incorrectly
I think what I want to do with this I
want to go about this
I mean I'm seeing the multi- discreet as
a possible candidate
okay okay this should be all zeros right
and then what do we
do the
3 2
1 5
eight yeah they got lots of actions
right so they should definitely be doing
something so possibly the action
handling logic is
renderer and where is
it be in the step function towards the
bottom forgot how much code this
was step
players okay so actions
ah right
here divided by 100.0
F that's not
good so this is why it's screwy at least
this is why it's slow not why it's
screwy
that dividing by
100 what if I just
this
what just let me move
magnitude I think it's supposed to be
times three isn't it
movement so I I think it's supposed to
be like 3 * Dy + 3 or
uh divided by 3.0 F minus
3 something like
this do minus three is
fine oh that does something
they just went
flying so this is definitely an incode
issue let me grab something real quick
one second
probably this needs to be rounded but
what's wrong with this
no
Precision okay hold
on let's go back to
this maybe I had a point
what did we say the type of the actions
are inar
do minus
3 times 100 right
what happened
here misleading
indentation
there well my movement's back to normal
right but now they're stationary again
it's always selecting
three
I mean assumedly these things should be
doing something right
what's print I don't know what's
printing but this is a valid
printing so this is a valid model right
that we're loading here we can see that
when I load this this is now the local
version the uh the pytorch version
right we have they're not super smart
but they do something and
then let's see yep there goes the
Knight we can follow him into
battle oh yep there he goes there's his
engage there he goes he's going to tank
the tower for
me oh look at that he took the tower I
he might I can't tell if he was supposed
to die there yeah there he
goes okay
so we definitely do have an
inconsistency of some type here
right the question is going to be what's
the best way to find
it so it going to be fixed data through
each Network
probably
right we put fixed data through each
Network and we see what
happens it's pretty obnoxious to set
that up but uh we can do
it probably that'll be the fastest
I'm going to take uh a quick break
now and then I'm going to come back and
I'm going to do that I got to do a
couple quick things and then uh I'm
going to come back and we're going to
finish this all
right I've got to uh do a couple quick
things in chat with a guy and then I'll
be back and my hope is that tonight
we'll get this working that's my goal so